let's say that there are four people in
a room and you're probably tired of me
naming the people with letters but I'm
going to continue doing that so the four
people in the room our persons a or
people a b c and d and they are all told
look you don't know each other so I want
you to all meet each other so you need
to shake the hand exactly once of every
other person in the room so that you all
meet so my question to you is if each of
these persons each of these people need
to shake the hand of every other person
exactly once
how many handshakes are going to occur
the number of handshakes that are going
to occur so like always pause the video
and and see if you can make sense of
this
all right I'm assuming you've had a go
at it so one way to think about it is
okay if you say there's a handshake
well a handshake has to two people are
party to a handshake we're not talking
about some new three person handshake or
four person handshake we're just talking
about the traditional two people shake
their right hands and so there's one
person there's another person that's
party to and it's you say okay there's
four possibilities of one party and if
we assume people aren't shaking their
own hands which we are assuming or
they're always going to shake someone
else's hand then for the other party
there's only three other prop for each
of these four possibilities who's this
party there's three possibilities who's
the other party and so you might say
that there's four times three handshakes
since there's four times three I guess
you could say possible handshakes and
what I'd like you to do is think a
little bit about whether this is right
whether there would actually be twelve
handshakes well you might have thought
about it you might say well you know
this four times three this would count
this is actually counting the
permutations this is counting how many
ways can you permute four people into
two buckets the the two buckets of hand
shakers where you care about which
bucket they are and whether they're
their hand shaker number one or hand
shaker number two this would count this
would count a being the number one hand
shaker and B being the number two hand
shaker as being different than B being
the number one hand shaker
and a being the number two hand shaker
but we don't want both of these things
to occur we don't want you know a to
shake B's hand we're you know a is
facing north and B is facing south and
then another time we need to shake hands
again where now B is facing north and a
is facing south so we don't have to do
it once these are actually the same
thing so no reason for both of these to
occur so we are going to be double
counting so what we really want to do is
think about combinations one way to
think about it is you have four people
in a world of four people or a pool of
four people how many ways can you choose
to how many ways to choose to choose two
because that's what we're doing
each handshake is just really a
selection of two of these people and so
we want to say how many ways can we
select two people so that we have a
different each combination each of these
ways to select two people should have a
different combination of people in it if
two of them had this do the same kind of
a b and b a these are the same
combination and so this is really a
combinations problem this is really
equivalent to saying how many ways are
there to choose two people from a pool
of 4 or 4 choose 2 or 4 choose 2 and so
this is going to be well how many ways
are there where how many ways are there
to permute 4 people into 3 spots which
is going to be 4 times 3 which we just
figured out right over there which is 12
actually wanted to do in that green
color so you see where that came from so
4 times 3 and then you're going to
divide that by the number of ways you
would arrange to you can arrange two
people well you can arrange two people
in two different ways ones on the left
ones on the right or the other ones on
the left and the other ones on the right
or you could also view that as 2
factorial which is also equal to 2 so we
could write this down as 2 so this is
the number of ways number of ways to
arrange two people to arrange two people
two people two people
and this up here this up here is let me
just in a new color this up here that's
the permutations that's the ways number
of permutations if you take two people
from a pool of four so here you would
care about order and so one way to think
about it this too is correcting for this
double counting year and if you want to
apply the formula you could I just kind
of reasoned through it again I mean you
could literally say okay four times
three is 12 we're double counting
because there's two ways to arrange two
people so you just divided it by two so
you just divide by two and then you are
going to be left with six you could
think of it in terms of this or you
could just apply the formula you could
just say hey look for choose two or the
number of combinations of selecting two
from a group of four this is going to be
4 factorial over 2 factorial times 4
minus 2 4 minus 2 factorial and let me
make this color different just so you
can keep track of how I'm at least
applying this and so what is this going
to be this is going to be 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 over 2 times 1 times
times this right over here is 2 times 1
so that will cancel with that 4 divided
by 2 is 2 2 times 3 divided by 1 is
equal to 6 and just really hit the point
home let's actually draw it out let's
draw it out
so a could shake b's hand a could shake
c's hand a could shake d's hand or b
could shake and let me just do what we
calculated first a 12 we could say B
could shake a's hand b could shake c's
hand B could shake whoops
B could shake Dee's hand and you can say
C could shake a's hands c could shake
b's hand c could shake succeed could
shake d's hand and you could say d could
shake a's hand d could shake b's hand d
could shake c's hand and this is 12
right over here and this is the
permutations if d shaking c's hand
is actually different than see taking
shaking Dee's hand then we would count
well but we just wanted to say well how
many ways they just have to meet each
other once
and so we're double counting so so a B
is the same thing as BA AC is the same
thing as CA ad is the same thing as DA
BC is the same thing as CB BD is the
same thing as DB CD is the same thing as
DC and so we'd be left with if we
correct for the double counting we're
left with one two three four five six
combinations six possible ways of
choosing two from a pool of four
especially when you don't care about the
order in which you choose them